hello my name is Emily first I just want
to say this is to talk about the history
of programming and I'm also gonna say
some very hand wavy things about a
cognition and neuroscience I am NOT an
expert on any of those topics and a lot
of the languages I'm going to talk about
are not actually around anymore to play
with us so I'm pulling these details
from papers and blog posts so if you
really like this topic I'm going to
tweet a link to all my references please
go check that out instead of believing
all the things I'm going to tell you and
because there's people out there who
know a lot more about this than I do by
day I am an engineering manager at
honeycomb I'm also a design and data
visualization nerd by night and I
studied architecture in school not
computer science and I made lots of
extremely weird visual physical things
then so many weird things like what is
this I made this thing I don't even know
what it is but I still had to read the
same academic handbook as the normal
kids and there was this one line in the
handbook that always made me really mad
and that line was to suppose that anyone
who cannot write clearly can think
clearly is an illusion words are the
most basic tools of thought to which my
response is skeptical face so think
about it for a minute picture in your
mind what you think the most basic
building blocks of thought are like
don't describe them with words picture
them so I don't think of words at all I
think of shapes and colors and symbols
and if you're anything like me maybe you
thought the same thing and there's a
really funny thing about this statement
when you think about it which is that
the words part of someone's brain made
this up like the verbal part made this
sentence up so you know asking the
verbal part of your brain what the most
basic tools of thought are is like
asking this dog like who is a good boy
like this is a wonderful dog but the dog
is not a neutral party
and there's some actual science that
bears us out so two famous researchers
Gazzaniga and Sperry studied patients
who had had the connections between
their brain hemispheres severed for
medical reasons so these people could
still use their left brain the more
verbal side and their right brain which
is the more spatial side but there
wasn't coordination between these two
halves of their brain and they found
that the different parts of the brain
actually think remarkably different
thoughts so they asked one patient like
to say his ideal career outloud and he
said draftsman very dependable and then
they asked him to point with his left
hand so he would use the right side of
his brain and having spell it out and
then he said he wanted to be an
automobile racer less dependable right
so you know when your hemispheres are
connected there's kind of chatter back
and forth between them and it helps you
stay synched up and not say strange
things that make your friends and family
kind of wonder about you but these kinds
of divergent thoughts are living in all
of our brains all the time and the
verbal part of your brain can't do
everything by itself like it could write
great papers but it doesn't produce all
this cool visual stuff so you know fast
board many years I have a very dignified
career as a programmer yes very
dignified it's great but everything is
in words like the code is in words pull
requests or in words documentation is in
words and all of this makes me ask like
what opportunities we don't see because
the verbal part of our brain is telling
us like words are the best you know so
I'm going to ask this question like what
if we programmed in pictures would we
think differently about our work and it
turns out that there's a lot of history
behind people exploring that what if so
I want to specifically talk today about
visual programming languages or VPLS
the the most likely example that you
might be familiar with is scratch
scratch came out of the Media Lab in
2002 it's designed to make it easy for
children to learn to program and make
creative projects and share their work
with other people this is a picture of
what the interface looks like at one
point the piece in the middle is the
actual program so you zoom and they'll
that that's hello world and scratch very
neat and the pieces kind of snap
together like you can drag them around
you can change values with a keyboard
press a button to run the thing it's
very intuitive unless you think like
that's not really programming it does
have all the right pieces so it has
conditionals that has loops variables
event handlers and some
hacker news even told me it's
turing-complete you know so there's that
so the program that you're looking at up
here is a very simple physics engine and
it kind of looks like a toy but you can
use this to write real programs so that
was 2002 but this idea actually goes way
way back to the 1960s the first good
example we have is sketch pad from 1963
this ran on something called the ran
tablet and it use this light pen as
input you might think that there would
be this slow evolutionary process that
led to our modern tools but you actually
see some of these tools coming up with
like nine different new innovations at
once so this might be the first
graphical user interface ever I think
and you would kind of draw on the screen
with a pen and you would use this series
of switches that were on the left side
to kind of describe how you wanted this
input to be transformed so you would
draw on the screen the computer would we
draw it for you which is what you see on
the right and this was kind of a
precursor to the modern CAD tools we see
today and one of the most interesting
things about this is that this is
actually object-oriented like the tool
understands your groupings of lines and
it would know that these were
independent objects that were grouped
together and that would kind of do the
same operations on them separately and
which is cool Grail is another language
from this area and also from this era it
also ran on the ran tablet so this is
the first example of a flow chart based
programming language you'd actually draw
those different sections of the program
and draw lines to connect them up and it
would even use an OCR like technology to
turn the drawings and letters you drew
into into program components into the
names of things which is kind of
fascinating when you think about it like
we've been working on OCR for over 50
years now and it's still only work some
of the time another one I thought was
really interesting was Pygmalion which
the creator had this thesis that part of
the complexity of programming was
holding all of the mental model of your
program state in your head and so he
wanted to be able to show all the state
on-screen which is what you see in those
boxes so the idea was every piece of
state your program you could just sort
of look at it all at once it also uses
this program programming by example
paradigm so you would kind of show the
program what to do with your data I
showed each step in this remember mode
and then you could use that to output
like a program that you could take with
you and run against an arbitrary input
later another favorite one of mine this
is cube from 1995 this is I've been told
the very first 3d visual programming
which I have no idea how this works like
galaxy brain right I just looked at this
picture and I was like I have to put
this on the slide so this is all very
fun but what's the catch there are some
things that are very hard to do in
visual languages
abstraction is really hard you probably
have to create a new paradigm to do that
difficut merging are really hard like if
you made this beautiful visual thing and
I made my visual thing like how do we
determine what's different and merge
them together it's really hard to show
that and it turns out that your face can
only absorb so many shapes like we have
a much better memory for unique words
than we do for unique shapes so it's
really hard to work with like lots of
different tokens at once so just to dig
into one of those problems in a little
more detail like let's talk about
abstraction there are lots of different
types of abstractions but let's think
specifically about procedural
abstraction like how do you take a piece
of code and make some shorthand for it
so you can reuse it over and over
there's a program called agent sheets
that solves this in this neat kind of
recursive way so this is a block based
programming tool but the interesting
thing is that the blocks can be nested
so if you want code reuse you just make
one of those blocks which is what you
see on the left side and then you just
stuff it into other blocks and then it's
almost like a subroutine or something
like you just pick blocks second-team
block seconding blocks it's cool
different languages have handled this in
different ways that are kind of similar
but you know subtly different so this is
chimera which is a graphical editing
tool and it's solution is to have this
sidebar of every operation you've ever
done I kind of rendered visually and
then you could clip out sets of
operations and save them as subroutine
or as a macros and then I could drag
them back in to apply them later almost
like a filmstrip may be the best
solution out there comes from pro graph
which is a language from the 80s this is
a data flow based language to me it
looks exactly like mousetrap which both
excites me and horrifies me the cool
thing about program is it it's truly
object-oriented it has classes and has
inheritance so this box that you're
looking at here is a description of a
method you can assemble it by dragging
together of those little boxes and
drawing how data flows through them and
the methods can actually then be
minified into little icons you can
package your method up and take it with
you and then all of your
objects are represented as these
hexagons so if you clicked on the left
side of the hexagon you could see all of
the classes and instance variables
associated with that object but if you
click on the right side then you could
see all the methods attached to it so
all those little squares there this is
really neat is really cool it worked
well and professional programmers
actually use this language but you also
noticed that by being less literal all
of a sudden new programmers really do
you need to learn all these difficult
programming concepts so the point is
like most of these languages either
don't have a good solution to this kind
of abstraction or they have to come up
with some totally new novel design
solution and then the complexity of that
kind of works against all of the the
good things the good goals that you had
for your VPL to begin with and then of
course you know take that process
repeat that for the dozens of different
problems that we already talked about so
back to that first question I wanted to
know like did we really deliver on this
promise of changing the way that people
think about programming the answers are
kind of unclear like a lot of people
anecdotally will say yes like if I use
CAD or if I use one of these tools like
I have this different brain space that
I'm in and I come up with different
kinds of ideas but there's really not a
lot of science on this the one good
paper I could find about the cognitive
effects of visual programming looked at
a couple different studies and found
very mixed results there's some evidence
that shows that visual programming
languages might be easier to learn but
the one thing that shows up over and
over again is that programmers have a
bias in favor of whichever programming
mode they learn first
so programmers who use text-based
languages are likely to call them easier
to learn and more powerful programmers
who use visual languages first are
likely to say those are easier to learn
a more powerful and to me the takeaway
from that is just that programmers
really like to disagree with each other
but we already knew that so there are
really successful cases for these
languages though they could be great for
occasional programming tests so this is
a cool example from Twilio Twilio studio
and you could use this to build out your
companies like public facing phone
system the person who wants to do this
is very likely not a professional
programmer and they probably want to
change it very infrequently so there's
actually this great benefit to having
the flow of the whole system displayed
really clearly and
having to learn a bunch of syntax IOT
devices are another good example they're
often used by hobbyists you see lots of
flow based models in the space kids
programming is another one like this is
Cody you kids make beautiful games with
this and then finally there are all
these great examples of creative tools
so this is Alice which is a design to
appeal to populations that might be less
served by traditional programming tools
by encouraging narrative and
storytelling so this is great like we
see these cases of where these tools are
making programming more accessible and
to me that means all of a sudden I don't
care so much about that question like if
these tools are making it possible for
people to leap the gap from being a non
programmer to being a programmer I don't
care as much if they change the way we
think so if there's one thing from all
this that I want to take back to my day
to day life it's noticing like I noticed
that my tools are primarily text I
noticed that it's rare to see pictures
and visualizations while I'm programming
and I notice that text bias is my
thinking in certain ways and I ask like
what am I missing by not showing this
some other way the very last example I'm
going to leave you with it's not
database at all this is a project called
github selfies
it's a browser extension that reminds
you to add a selfie of yourself whenever
you submit a PR so yeah I love this it's
like take something text-based that can
feel a little impersonal like stop a
reminder of your humanity right in the
middle of it and see if it changes the
way you think about contributing so take
away notice an experiment and don't be
fooled by text trying to tell you that
text is always the best answer thank you
[Applause]